[Music]
hello welcome to film independent
presents virtual edition i'm matt warren
uh senior content manager
digital content manager here at film
independent
and before we get started with today's
uh very cool q a i'd love to give a
shout out to
our loyal supporters of this program
thank you to our lead sponsor the
hollywood foreign press association and
our virtual screening partner vision
media
and now
uh i'm honored to introduce our guests
for today uh here to talk about their
great new film small engine repair we
have
writer director and actor
john pilano and actors shay wiggum and
john bernthal welcome guys thanks for
having us thank you how you doing man
john bernthal is also a producer of the
movie so let's not lose that he uh oh
yes
and he was no joke as the producer he
was he really he pushed that boulder up
the hill as much as anybody i'm not i'm
not being sarcastic it's hard with this
group everything i say sounds like it's
bullshit but i'm being i'm waiting for
the shoe to drop you know
yeah i i neglected that in the intro but
i have a question about uh the producing
side of things for john a little bit
later so don't worry we'll definitely
get to that
um uh well i'm i'm excited to talk to
you guys about this film uh i saw it
last night and
uh
john p i want to start with you uh this
is uh based on a play you originally
wrote is that correct yes correct
we ain't seen each other in a long time
[Music]
i got steaks i got booze i got beer
we are hanging out
as rodeo tonight got a new tv huh i did
i mean mine's bigger but what
hey what's up it's frank
yeah you just uh you just keep going on
93 north for a while and then you'll uh
you'll see my shop it's the only place
for this light on who's coming over
frank oh we got to get out of this you
didn't think about it no no
i wanted tonight to be special
you know i was writing plays for a
little bit at that point and a lot of
things was like you know i wanted to
tell stories and i wasn't dialed into
the industry so i couldn't you know make
a movie so i was and i loved theater i
was writing that and that's how i met uh
john john bernthal he was in i think the
second reading ever of the play and then
you know it was a very very modest late
night show it started at like 10 30 10
45 at night after all the main stage
plays left it was like a little 50-seat
theater you know it was super rowdy it
was very loud people were drinking the
whole time dropping beer bottles and it
was you know it was intentionally
created to be a very provocative sort of
foul-mouthed unfiltered roller coaster
ride and that was sort of the and and to
be quite honest you know as we were
rehearsing and doing everything we're
like jesus i don't know people may walk
out of this we don't know if people are
going to get it and they did and it was
it just connected in a way
and you know the play has been done all
over the world but we really get to
battle test the material and you know
john and i
you know hit it off and we're always
like oh this would be such a great movie
uh an indie because it's primarily
contained and we know the characters and
but but mostly we're like we just caught
lightning in a bottle with some of this
stuff
and then uh you know we always batted it
back and forth over as our careers took
off and john was like you know doing so
much
and um but the themes of the play which
was written in 2011 just became more
sort of relevant so we were like well
shit we gotta we gotta do this as a
movie and then you know it was uh and
then honestly everything clicked into
place and it was like the most wonderful
experience
until sort of covet hitting and and kind
of fucked up our release plan but prior
to that it was really like meant to be
and we couldn't have been more blessed
with you know finding shay and and
everything kind of happening john's
schedule opened up shea's schedule
opened up and we just like moved so uh
you know that's the benefit of an
independent movie you can be pretty
agile with that kind of shit
and shay when did you get involved with
this because it sounds like john was
there from it's it's very origins but
when did this come across
yeah they were there john
didn't uh john bernthal didn't you i
think you approached me we were
we were already
you know we knew each other and i think
john approached me and gave it to me and
you know
um
i read it
uh you know
everything made me nervous scared me you
know based on the history of it and i
had to come in and um
you know
packy and so i came in you know when i
once i came in it was we were these guys
were ready
to roll you know i had a couple months
preparation and then we prepared we went
and lived together for
a week in new york city and just did the
thing that you always wanted to have the
luxury of doing it is just sit around
and talk and hash it out and get to know
each other organically so you don't
force things and
it was one of the most magical
experiences i've had
making a film
and you know i'm imagining
all of you you three as performers sort
of
uh
connecting over this this period of time
and
i i'm always curious how a group of
actors in a titan ensemble like this
work together to find the right energy
for a film you know so that their
performances match and everyone seems
like they're in the same movie
um i'm wondering if between the three of
you you could talk about that process a
little bit of all kind of getting on the
same page
well i think it's a lot about you know
what what shay just sort of said
spending that time together look i i
think uh
we we all knew
you know pretty pretty pretty well who
who each other were you know before this
started what we what's important to us i
mean if you you know
john and i have
you know over 10 years of of friendship
and and working together our families
are enormously close uh i'm enormously
close with shay and his family we know
each other we know but if you you you
know what kind of
what kind of artist shea is you know you
know what he's about he puts the work
above everything else you can see in
everything that he does and i've known
that from him knowing him in person i
would know that if i just knew him
through his performances i i think um
you know i agree this this has been a
magical
experience for me since since the play
it's just oh it's it's it's exactly the
it's the right way to put it it's been
magical it's it's full of heart it's um
it it's always felt um just beautiful
and righteous and a real real real
blessing and i think sometimes those
things we make it
you know harder than it needs to be i
think if you surround yourself by people
who you believe in an artist that you
really really respect
you know
most of the time
you know there's not a lot of you know
ego or anything that gets in the way
it's it's people that really want to
challenge each other and push each other
and and dig into it as as quickly as
possible and that's really what what
this was by and everybody who worked on
it on the film
listen man i
i can categorically say this film
wouldn't have worked
without exceptional actors and the whole
construct of the production was it's
basically a a performance delivery
system basically and the the actors you
know the story is very sturdy it's very
simple and the characters are
it's about relationships it's love and
it's heart and it's danger and if you
don't have the right actors it's just
not going to work and
i always i love the kind of actors that
i love to watch and work with are actors
who are kind of just listening and
they're more about getting an effect out
of the other character than they are
about you know being a soloist and stuff
like that so i mean working with john i
knew he had that and obviously seeing
his work and just knowing how he is and
you know john's the type of actor he
like emerges from uh from a movie or a
show and he has new friends because he's
like this is who i am and he's just so
generous with that and so when he you
know brought up shay whose work you know
i loved shae's work i was like
i mean i didn't immediately see him as
paki because i saw i saw shea as like a
dark scary like motherfucker and most of
the stuff he did i mean i sort of
discovered him in boardwalk empire in
times it's all new information to me i
thought he didn't want you at all man i
had to fight no he hadn't he had to
fight because i was like jesus christ
i'm blown away right now
so but but you talk to him and you
realize that like because by the way i'm
very protective of paki i mean
in all the different plays and
iterations of every character i've ever
written he is in in some ways the most
sort of
singular
literary invention i've i think i've
ever done in that he's just so unique
and
and you know you've never seen him in
another story and and he is so crucial
to to have it done right and and you
know i've seen productions of various
successes of doing paki and it just has
to nail it and and you know
shea brought that and it was great so
i knew john the you know from 2011 and
as the writing of the script and
everything it was like we kind of we
really collaborated a lot and it was
like writing for him and knowing him and
and then it was crucial to no shay as
well and then we all became friends
because i mean i don't think you could
fake that i just don't i don't think if
you had like you know some prima donna
actor come in and wanted to be in their
trailer and just went come out right
before action it just it wouldn't have
worked i mean you know we all just hung
out sitting around smoking cigarettes
and like drinking you know beer and you
know getting high every night and
working on the lines and just living it
you know so everyone was there there was
no trailers like you're off camera
you're freezing your ass off you're just
sitting there okay why do you say
cigarettes like that
cigarettes cigarettes well no because i
because you know i wasn't a smoker until
shane made me a smoker for a year and a
half
he's like bro he's like you can't smoke
on camera unless you do it right this is
how you do it not one or two he's like
your homework is to smoke that whole
pack and then like a month into it i'm
like i'm fucking addicted to cigarettes
amounts of red wine yeah a lot of red
wine yeah
yeah would you consider that your big
contribution to the film shay is getting
john to smoke a bunch of cigarettes it's
just the small things matt it's the
little thing man you know what i mean
well
it's like that actually i mean we're
joking but that kind of actually goes
into a question i had and
um
uh you know
the johns and shea i'm fans of yours but
i actually don't know that much about
um
your backstory or where you're from or
anything like that and just the
specifics of the
the milieu in small engine repair i
think are so key to
making it feel
real and like these are real
relationships and a real situation that
these people aren't
what um
john p i know you're from the area kind
of depicted in the film but are
either of the other two of you from this
sort of new england area
uh no uh i'm i'm from washington dc and
uh
but but i've spent time there and and
and look i i think uh
you know
we've been with it i've been with the
story for for for a long time but i i
look i think a big part of that is just
really the the the dialect and and and
and the the rhythms and the the it's in
the writing um but you know we we had
tim monach who's who's the the best
style dialect coach you know out there
working he did us an enormous favor he
came on and really invested a lot in
this film and and um took us through it
and got everybody there and um
you know he's one of the true sort of
you know
you know really
just heroes of this this industry if you
look at the things that he's done and
the performances that he's helped sort
of uh you know bring to light and and
and
and support it's it's astonishing um and
you know i think he he's another guy he
just puts the work first and i think he
he loved how much this all meant to us
how hard we were working at it he really
just gave us his time which was such a
blessing and such a gift
and is there anything else from a
performance standpoint that our is maybe
a specific in the
physicality of of getting these
characters right like i'm pretty i'm
thinking of packing in particular who
are just seems like so slumped under
you know his different layers of
clothing and you know just you know
these these layers of clothing sort of
representing the decades of just
this
this sort of grim treadmill he's been on
uh you know shea was wondering if you
could speak to sort of the physicality
of paki as a character at all yeah
yeah
um that was definitely when i when i
started this again i speak about the
pressure you can't
it's hard to understand the pressures of
this thing being done 800 times in los
angeles and then they brought it to new
york and it almost you know i mean just
kept
and it were four or five packets you
know and so the pressure of knowing what
they had and i i just started
i started with um
i knew i had to get down i wanted to go
really down i wanted to make myself
smaller around these two
large in the life cats you know because
we've known each other forever and i'm
always interested
in a lot of things but what happens to
friendships as they
evolved you know what i mean and paki
did was stunted and i i started there
and then the physicality i wanted to
make myself small but still tough but
not
not
you know
sway no tough you know what i mean and
frank is spending time in the can you
know but
so i just yeah that was important to me
to you know i think it
i don't know i think it really helped me
a lot
one thing
for sure we look man
i i think when you work with great
actors especially these guys who like
friends what was really cool and i don't
know how it usually is for them but
they both were in integral in terms of
dirk working with the hairstylist the
makeup the wardrobe the props
everything so and it was really cool
like i knew john had that level
but it was really cool watching uh shay
be so meticulous about it about
everything and then
you know it's not just like
a way to distract him or or make him
feel at ease which i've seen some actors
do it's like then you see the
performance and you realize that's all
like he just does that little layer at a
time and and he lost an incredible
amount of weight and and he was eating
like fucking like beef jerky and oatmeal
like once a day or something i mean it
was crazy actually shame commitment here
really well it was insane and i i know i
i i really respect
sort of what what you were saying there
shane a minute ago about you know he he
did come into it with real i think
sometimes whether you want to call it
fear or reverence or respect but the
fact that other people have done it i
knew that that was really driving him
you know his level of commitment here
and and and the work is just sort of
astonishing and i think what really
takes it to this other level
with shay is that you know it's not it's
not just about himself and his choices
and his costume he's there with you in
the scene and he's telling you come on
come on give me give me some more let's
go again like we have the ability to all
be with each other in these scenes and
to work with each other in this very
egoless and and supportive way and it's
truly
you know i think the the the sort of it
it's the sublime ultimate of what
ensemble acting can actually be you know
when you just have a group that is all
there pushing each other uh uh spurring
each other on and and and
you know i remember there was a key time
in the key scene where you know shay
asked for he told me to do it one more
time he was like you know let's do that
one more time
leveled me and and you know and and you
know when you get this close
you know it's it's uh you know he can
just look you in the eye and you know
where you need to go and uh it's an
unbelievable uh selfless unbelievably
selfless
sort of approach and and a caring
approach and and that's that's these
guys in a nutshell but um you know i
just want to say that
shea's commitment was staggering but it
wasn't only about about himself yeah i
mean that's that's kind of so it's
so nice i
think they're cliches i find within
acting and one of them is a generous
actor
but i hold on to that like a vice grip
i'm always trying to be generous i would
i would rather be
you know john and john be better in the
scene than myself and i i always i i
always go into every project like this i
remember meryl streep saying to
i
on she devil i think of all i remember
her saying to uh
her other actress part i'm going to be
better off camera for you i'm going to
do my best acting off camera
and you do your best acting all camera
for me you know what i mean and that
these these these these these simplistic
you know things that you hang your hat
on a lot of times you come back to them
you know what i mean just talking and
listening you know these guys have done
it so many times
they can they they're amazing they're
great actors he wrote it he wrote it for
with him in mind and so if i can be
there every once in a while and go
what about that maybe maybe not or this
they would do the same thing john would
come in and we all want to whisper you
know i don't know think about this i
don't know uh nope yep yeah yeah yep yep
so
you know that's that's beautiful
i i think it's
super cool that you had that um
sort of collaboration going where you
felt empowered to make suggestions and
that kind of goes to a question i had
for uh john p
uh
in making the the jump to to film
obviously you're adapting a a a script
that is very
you know dialed in for a different
medium is there anything in that jump
that you found you had to extend you
know exaggerate for film or
tone down for film so that it would kind
of have the effect that you were hoping
to have you know uh the the play was the
play had more zingers more humor that
was set up and
you know a little more monologuey a
little more
um just theatrical
even though it was very grounded and
felt real the movie
became evident very quickly that it was
it was more natural and it was much more
dangerous
and the movie's funny but the humor is
thrown away in theater there's obviously
you know there's a technique to it the
audience has to hear it you can't
overlap you can't do all that stuff it's
it's about performing the same time
every night and you're creating the
illusion of of naturalness but the movie
it was just these characters were real
people
and the stakes were way higher because
you're there and everything was just
more serious and a lot of the jokes that
were show stoppers in the play are in
the movie but they're thrown away in the
way that like again for me i tried to
create a movie and we were all on the
same page as that as you watch something
like goodfellas first time you watch
goodfellas you may be horrified and like
shit then you watch it again and you're
like geez this is a fucking comedy i
didn't know it and then you see it again
and you realize oh wow that's an it's a
statement on something
and and that's very much what this was
so the humor and all that stuff it's
just thrown away so it didn't have that
so i gave up really quick that you're
not going to be able to recreate those
zinger moments and it's just going to be
real and and from the heart and you know
these guys are ball busting i mean again
there was the scene that we shot
where like shae's character where pakis
on the car and he's mooning swanno and
doing all that stuff there's like three
lines that are overlapped and thrown
away that in the play you set up because
it was like show stop or showstopper and
it just happens organically and it's
it's not that it's not funny it's just
real so that was something that i gave
up trying to be funny and and lean more
into the
the reality of it now it's very funny
because these guys naturally are but
that that was the biggest thing and and
uh yeah it just it was just darker and
deeper the movie
i i can i can totally because as i was
watching the film last night i could
sort of
um
you know i sort of imagined what the
screenplay might look like and i imagine
you know a lot of that dialogue
kind of just looking a lot more like
jokes written out than it is uh
performed i mean i think it's it's a
very funny
film in a lot of ways but i i can see
how
uh
in in a different setting that aspect of
the film would be a lot more uh
accentuated
right and well and then in the theater
as as john b always used to say is like
especially the third act of the movie is
like it's like a magic trick
it's all one act the play and you're the
audience is like how far are they going
to go with this so it becomes like again
a magic trick let's just see how they go
and that's part of the enjoyment in it
obviously in a film you don't have that
so you're sort of when you're derailed
the audience is like truly derailed
because you couldn't do anything so
there's no uh there's no safety of how
far are they gonna go
um which was kind of cool so that yeah
it was you know it was
definitely scary
but you know the pre-production of it
with the dp matt mitchell i mean we we
figured out
meticulously how every shot was going to
go
and then but when we shot there it was
like
we know the story we know the beats just
let it go let it let it sort of live its
life and not be precious with any of it
and you know there's a degree of
improvisation and then you come back to
the script and you do it and then in the
edit we'd carve it out but it was like
just to feel real and natural and not
you know
playing at it yeah i mean look i can't
see any other way i i mean
someone gave me really good advice
before though like you're gonna figure
out what kind of director you are
and i was like well this is it because i
love actors and i love acting and i'm
like you just have to hire the best
actors and and really trust them and let
them let their instincts go and just
kind of give them a roadmap and let it
go i mean there were so many moments
where
you know the camera's on shea and john
and they're like riffing on the couch
and it's just they're just going at it i
mean we shot so much of that and you're
like then you get into edit and you're
like they're little gifs you can't use
it all but like by the way it's super
fun to act that you know
to get that but as opposed to going in
there and being like this is it hit it
hit it hit it move on you know uh so i
just love that that collaborative
that they could feel the need to do it
and but you know man i'd have john pull
me aside and be like listen bro why
don't even as an actor be like why don't
you do that again or shay so everyone
had each other's backs and it was like
what's wrong with that it's like great
you know
yeah and and sort of sort of on that uh
i don't want to
i don't want to run out of time without
circling back to uh john b's role on
this film as a producer
and and john i was wondering
as a producer what
at each stage in pre-production
production
and now sort of post slash distribution
what do you think has been
your most important
uh contribution as a producer during
each of those phases man uh important i
i look the whole thing is it has been
has always been about
you know and i i i think what's key to
producing period is supporting your
filmmaker just supporting john you know
this was a monumental task that he took
on he wrote this he directed it and he
started it uh that's uh
yeah you know and and before this thing
started i i sat him down and i said hey
man are you sure you want to do this are
you sure you want to take all this on
and he looked me dead in the eye and he
said i'm absolutely sure i want to take
all this on there was no question about
it and um i'm so
i'm so grateful that that that that he
he
he
he had that kind of fortitude and that
kind of strength and that kind of
courage to to do this
um so it was really just just just being
there for him in every in every way i
think a lot of the the casting decisions
um
you know they they really they weren't
they
they really kind of made themselves i
mean the right people kind of kind of um
showed up and it was sort of undeniable
i mean um
you know
kind of across the board and
and i think all the way through i mean
look it's an independent film um we did
not have a lot of money we were running
a gun in uh there was a lot of stuff
that we had to do on the fly and there's
all sorts of roles that you know when
i'm just an actor
you know it it it
you know you sort of feel like you're in
kind of this protective cushion and
you're responsible sort of for for your
performance and for the other folks and
there was something that i really
enjoyed you know when when when there
was a crisis being able to sort of step
forward and say hey let let me be a part
of handling this whatever it is and um
those things just happened in
independent film and i really enjoyed
that i think naturally i'm a pretty
protective person and i'm enormously
protective of john
yeah i i would just echo that like it
was
you know i think that there's definitely
productions where the lead actor is a
producer by name but like you know john
was a huge asset through i mean i
remember early on one of the teamsters
backed into this guy's car and he wanted
to start a fight as we're trying to
shoot a crucial scene before we lost the
light and i was like i'm trying to do
something what the fuck's going on and
john went after me he's like i got it
and he walked over to the guy and he's
like what's up guy and the guy like saw
john and he was like calm down but all
the producers were like sir sir and
john's like look man if you have a
problem let's just go over there he's
like i'm fine with it let's just go over
there i mean he literally did you can
hear him on the thing he's like he's
like i'm not worried at all and the guy
was convinced he's like no no it's okay
and then one of the producers wrote him
a check for 500 bucks so
not many producers will do that but then
you know and then also man you know he
he
has a barometer to the story doing it
and i gotta be honest like i was kind of
blown away how great john was in in in
post-production in the editing
you know he saved the opening of the
film we had
we shot the opening and it started it
wasn't supposed to snow until one and we
started shooting at nine and then it
started to snow at 10 and we lost the
coverage and his john's daughter plays
young crystal and the original in the
script she's supposed to come up and be
like daddy you've been gone and hug and
they go in and it was supposed to be
sort of a lighter beginning we got one
take of that and then it started to snow
or shoe fell off she's cold she's
holding johnny you want to go to me i
mean she knows me but she's like fuck
this so you know we kept we just shot as
much as we could and i didn't even know
the camera was rolling and there's a
moment where
shape was his anime he's like come on as
the director he's like it's fine it's
fine like and
then we were in the edit and we had like
little magical moments and we were
putting it together
and i was like i don't know i don't know
and then we're sitting there and john
was like what if we start you know with
a phone call and do this from that and
it was like those kind of moments i you
know you were trapped and and
he he figured it out so he he really was
great and all that stuff uh i i can
imagine scenarios where an actor like
john and shay are you know discouraged
on set because it's like they do have
these great ideas but like the way john
did it that was so
cool and thoughtful is he's like look
let's just talk about it and if i'm like
yeah i think about it but that's not
right let it go it's fine
but like take that minute when you work
with great collaborators to hear them
out
and i'll just say i had a very very
similar experience with shea who because
he was so invested in the material
became so productive of it he was like
the canary down the mine shaft packing
in particular in the play and in the
first earlier drafts of the script had
some more outlandish sort of
non-sequitur moments that on the day
felt a little big bang theory which
wasn't right and he was like look i'll
say this but it doesn't feel right
and then you're like you know you have
to listen to him because he is so deep
in that character
um it's his
and you know what i'm saying but like
it's not like hey my ego i mean most
actors don't want you to cut their lines
but you know when you work with
i think when you open yourself up to
those type of collaborations that's the
magic of the movie if you love the movie
and because of the the way it feels and
all that it's it's 100 attributable to
that collaboration and especially to
these guys who have done a lot more of
that shit than i am have
in just sort of opening their hearts in
in being that collaborative and creating
that space i mean it wouldn't have
happened without them
and and sort of on that my sort of final
just
question
uh before we wrap up here is
you know maybe
as i was watching the film maybe i was
thinking of this because i
knew about the film's sort of theatrical
origins but
could there ever be
uh sort of like a true west version of
small engine repair where you all like
swap roles or
is it is it's so tied to your
interpretation of these characters that
you just can't even imagine something
like that no i mean john and i back when
we were running originally we had talked
about swapping sueno and frank and how
fun that would be and uh
just you know it was a crazy idea we
were probably smoking weed and we just
ran out of time but i mean i for sure
could see that happening i think that's
really interesting um to change the
dynamic i mean look
it'd be awesome if someone took the play
and you know did that every every few
weeks they they swapped it up that'd be
cool okay well cool uh so
uh john p tell us where we can find uh
this film right now and how people can
uh find you and your work
uh well you can get smalling repair like
wherever you would buy an on-demand
movie i mean i always send people to
like amazon prime and voodoo and those
type things uh really uh amazon prime
seems to be the easiest one but i think
it's it's like on itunes it's like on
all that stuff wherever you would find
it you know
that's how most people are watching
movies nowadays and so i think they're
just have to dig a little bit
[Music]
you